If you were to walk up these stairs into that
building through a long hallway, you'd come
to the courtroom, where the Supreme Court
justices, dressed in their black robes, hear
their cases.
The Constitution establishes the judiciary
of which the Supreme Court is a part, as a
separate branch of the federal government.
Under the Constitution, it's empowered to
hear all cases arising under the Constitution,
under the Laws of the United States, and Treaties.
Alexander Hamilton called the judicial branch
the weakest branch of the federal government.
He noted that Congress has the power of money,
the president has the power of the military,
and the courts have the power only of judgment.
Meaning that the legitimacy of the courts
depends on the wisdom of their decisions.
Being the weakest branch does not mean, however,
that the Judiciary is a weak branch.
The Supreme Court is a very powerful institution.
Some of its decisions have as much impact
as a major act of Congress or an important
decision of the president.
Consider, for example, the Supreme Court's
decision in Citizens United in 2010.
In it, it declared that corporations and unions,
and by extension independent groups, can spend
unlimited amounts of money during election
campaigns.
That decision has changed the way that we
elect our officials.
In 2012, independent groups spent nearly a
billion dollars to try to influence the voters.
In 2014, they spent so much money that the
number of televised political ads doubled
from the previous midterm in 2010.